For this equation, x can equal negative 3 or 8 3rds. Good job if you got these
two correct. I hope you're becoming a pro at u substitution. First, we'll
perform the substitution and let u equal x minus 2. We'll replace x minus 2
with the variable u. Now that we have this equation, we need to move this 10 to
the left-hand side. So, we'll have a quadratic equal to 0. We factored this
quadratic expression by finding the factors of negative 30 that sum to positive
13. Those factors are negative 2 and positive 15. We rewrite the middle term
and then use factoring by grouping to get u plus 5 times 3u minus 2 equal to 0.
We use this factoring to solve for the variable u. So, we can have u equal
negative 5, or u equals 2 3rds. Finally, we use those solutions of u to figure
out the values of x. This was the original variable in our first equation. So,
since u equals negative 5. x minus 2 equals negative 5. And since u equals 2
3rds, we know that x minus 2 equals 2 3rds. We add 2 to both sides, to each
equation, so x can equal negative 3. Or x can equal 2 and 2 3rds. The mixed
number, or 8 3rds, the improper fraction. Nice problem solving if you got here.